Danny we've just seen jump duo's
dimensions yeah you love series oh you
think like first impression I love the
first do so much and then this could
have gone either way because the
original sort of conceptual dude who
made that game isn't involved in this
but this is a team guys who did work on
it some guys from prasar creations and I
think some folks from Studio Liverpool
as well as part of activations of Sierra
in the type of brown thing its first
five minutes on a super bummed because
it's not really geometry wars but it is
kind of soulja mature so basically in
lieu of it being a kind of five level
game where you are leaderboard hunting
each other over and over again this is
is a game is straight up has a campaign
a multiplayer co-op thing and a
competitive multiplayer aspect as well
now we only got to see the campaign
aspect of it
but what essentially that was was 50
levels in a linear structure some of
which were boss levels where you are
fighting waves much like in the original
geometry wars and retro evolve but
instead of there being on a 2d plane
it's just kind of like 3d things like in
Mario Galaxy i guess so we saw the one
that look like a cylinder and your when
you as you're moving around it like the
camera is planning along with you
similar enemies it looks and sounds
almost identical to the old games and
but ultimately you are playing a single
player game so you're fighting the game
whereas before I felt like you were
fighting your mates on the leaderboards
and the one thing once I started asking
them about God about the fact that the
leaderboard Hans seems to be a secondary
thing they kind of talk to the bit more
bad and it eased ease my concerns of it
so the the sort of overview map has got
a bunch of these levels in a row he said
that there would be way where and
made of yours over talk you in the
leaderboards were basically like pop up
a different color or something so
they're aware the fact that people have
like specific levels of their play over
and over with and they'd still want
people to be battling for leaderboards I
guess the problem is we need five levels
is really easy to have big lead fun
bites whereas with 50 it's maybe a bit
of a stretch your the other thing that
asks as well as happy bag was that stuff
like passive mode like The Endless mode
that they had in there which was
essentially the crux of geometry wars 2
and all that stuff in there but it's
just peppered treta main campaign of all
the 50 levels yeah it's like the first
one let me know first of all to be
normal and they're you know sort of easy
enough levels and then they're gonna
pepper those ones in there so it's kind
of like they got this great little game
and they've had to like stretch it to
cover what Activision wantam you know
it's it's just taking loads of boxes in
a way that the geometry wars didn't have
to but gentlemen the two guys we talked
to release on that team or making it
seem to have history with the franchise
they seem to get white people a lot like
this so I am cautiously optimistic
to be multi pops yes of course it's a
company at playstation 4 xbox one xbox
360 playstation 3 and pc all this year
and i asked them if they were going to
have leaderboards stretching across all
the platforms they said we can't tell
you that we don't know yet sounds like
they're trying to make that a reality
but I know like soft like Xbox sharing
the database the party it's quite
difficult so they're trying to but you
know that they can't confirm yet sure
the cautiously optimistic one for the
ladies different games come teaching
taken